back here on the D show with our brother
Ali and so we talked about it's not your
fault it's something if if the belief in
God this belief system becomes quanta
physics if it could become something so
convoluted that's a red light isn't it
that's I mean it's you know the the
better one in the desert the truck
driver the carpenter I mean just your
average layman who doesn't have much
education
he just has maybe just common sense and
he can understand look believe in one
God he's like I'm in that's it how you
start getting all complicated you make
things that that means man's hands have
been in it they've complicated things
could we make that that's a fair
assessment this is a very fair
assessment you can even see it another
you can see it empirically from other
religious traditions I mean you have you
don't have very many comforts to
Hinduism for instance you know they have
thousands and thousands of gods it's
usually a cultural something you're sort
of born into but you know so a lot of
the simple people in the world they're
not converting to these complicate
overly complicating religious traditions
you have a lot of simple individuals
converting to Christianity but for the
most part there usually is because they
don't understand even what a Trinity
means you know they're very much
attached to the personality of Jesus but
they don't if you gave them a book on
the Trinity they would completely lose
any sense for what Christianity even
stands for yeah it's not the package is
good look someone you know love love
love and just believe this and you're
going to paradise and God sent you know
someone to die for your sins you got a
big load of debt and you put it on the
JC gold card but that's not me I mean
that's not being fair I mean that's not
me
now that that's it's a great marketing
tool yeah but today anybody who takes
even a few minutes to comprehend their
to contemplate what these things mean
will eventually I think honestly those
honestly speaking well eventually you
know I include anymore but I think
Christians are feminine more emotion
actually more election and that's not
because it's all my teachers or Catholic
philosopher and I respect intellect but
the lay person the common person on the
street you know is not it just it
doesn't because it goes over their head
way too much yeah yeah and now you went
from this whole journey and now you had
a Muslim friend and he takes you into a
mosque I mean this is what I tell people
a lot of the Islamophobes you know
people who become experts Islam in Islam
they never stepped into a mosque you
know they never sat and really had a
sincere one-to-one
heart fill can made a human connection
with some Muslims and really sat with
some scholars Muslim scholars to learn
but they all of a sudden become experts
you were you scared you actually now you
had Muslim he brought you into it to a
mosque I think if more people did this
for a step they just came into a mosque
ask questions this would be a
problem-solver in itself yeah I agree I
think this is a big problem especially
Islamic laws but we don't have any sort
of personal connection with Muslims in
general or even the intellectual
tradition because they I mean if they
want nothing to do with it my journey
towards Islam began in philosophy
courses which is interesting because you
often hear there are negative
connotations about what philosophy is
and how it affects people's faith though
I would argue that a deep understanding
philosophy actually leads you towards
faith rather than the opposite but
that's moving another conversation
I was already sort of bowing to the
point where I kind of lost my
Christianity so now I was venturing
forth trying to find what was the true
religion
I still believed in God I didn't make
the superficial jump from religion all
the way Katie isn't like a lot of these
atheists do these days I was looking for
which theory which construct explained
God explained religion the best so I
went I looked at the Eastern religions I
looked into Judaism you know and then
finally actually my last option was
Islam because of the negative portrayals
in the media which you know I feel
ashamed for having gone into at that
time that you know we're not always
perfectly rational human beings you were
a victim like you fell victim like many
people many millions have become victim
to that yeah so i mean i mean i wasn't
like an open bigot or anything but I
still I had my reservations as a result
of those images so as I said you know
humans are perfectly rational I never
claimed to be so obviously you know some
of the things that we believe in in our
lives
you know we can be illogical about so
but when I met this young man in my
philosophy course he was very kind to me
he showed great depth and for me he was
a good example and so I called him to
the Masjid for several months I visited
with the Imams and eventually I was
intellectually convinced of this now but
you know there's always a disconnect
sometimes you know being intellectually
convinced doesn't necessarily mean being
spiritual kingdoms and that came a
little later when I had actually care
with care in the u.s. it was a council
they were doing this give away free
Quran month or something for non-muslims
to sort of it in you know so I signed up
for it I was expecting this little
pamphlet to come in the mail you know
like maybe this tiny they sent me this
massive book actually I have it in my
bookshelf behind me I should get it sure
you and they came in and Mary was so
heavy I can very well yesterday right
yeah the black in the gold calligraphy
they have on it
yeah Mohammed I saw the translation and
I thought they had sent me you know no
more than one maybe by accident or
something I open it up mass beautiful
book and I started reading and English
obviously cuz I though I didn't know
whatever and I remember 23:24 where it
specifically talks about your parents
and there's actually a very part
wrenching for me because you know before
I get to the ISS because in my culture
between all the Spanish cultures you
sort of get very close to your parents
and I mean you war but not to be
expected it that it is this idea you
know don't you get it teen rapid or you
know what I mean you see your parents on
holidays and being disrespectful sort of
a normal thing okay so when it said you
know have mercy on your parents as they
had mercy on you when when they raised
you when you were young you know that
kind of that that that really don't know
how that clicked it just did and it
really hurt me actually I felt actually
extreme amount of pain in my heart
that's the best way I can describe it I
felt guilty I felt ashamed of myself
I felt absolutely wretched as a person
and even today you know I struggle
trying to get over that cultural issue
but that was the first time that I felt
that way about my behavior towards my
mother my father and I remember when
that hit me you know the first thing
that I did and I was living in Chicago
at the time he's really cold by the way
outside I remember going outside without
a jacket and I remember you know I saw
my friend praying with his head to the
ground and so I felt I had to be
grateful so the only way I knew how to
be grateful in the context that it's not
imposed to put my head to the ground I
didn't know what I was doing so I picked
the direction in the middle of the snow
I'm outside of my apartment where it's
like I don't know what temperature it
was and
I put my head to the ground and I said
thank you and I think that was the first
time that I had the spiritual connection
to Islam which sort of finally confirmed
a me what I should do and there was one
more thing that pushed me further
because even though I had that spiritual
connection you know I had two
intellectual connection I still was
scared because you know the negative
portrayals of Islam in the media what
were people going to think of me when I
said I'm a Muslim no he called
terrorists a traitor
you know treated like garbage and that's
actually what happened but before that
getting the motivation to move in that
direction to finally take my Shahada was
when I was doing some research about my
history and I it was just something I
was curious about because I was reading
about al-andalus you know the time when
the Muslims had taken Spain and had
controlled Spain quite some time who
made that dynasty and that civilization
so I started researching and which which
in Spanish means like rosary and those
in the Catholic tradition that the pesky
the beads yeah but you know a lot of
Muslims used to do liquor and I found
out that my last name traced back only
five hundred years I couldn't find any
other records before that and then I
also found out that five hundred years
ago from this time period was something
called the Reconquista which the
Reconquista was the was when Queen
Isabella from the North came in and
invaded Spanish al-andalus and conquered
so the Christians had conquered the
Muslims and pushed us out and all the
Muslims remaining in that region were
either forced to convert
actually posed to convert the
Catholicism or to be exiled or killed
and they would change the names of the
Muslims who were converted so for
instance one of the names of the
Moriscos people who were forced to
convert was Rosario because of the fact
that these particular family members
used to be seen with what they tells the
the Tessa P so I found out that my
family Gerry
then I which could be respectable events
Wow
so you were going back to the original
way not not just spiritually what was
the original way with all the prophets
with Jesus well even your family yeah so
I don't actually from way back we
Muslims it's basically I thought that I
like my favorite kind parents at
migration Spain to Puerto Rico and then
very deep we got a couple almost Italian
couple more questions can you tell me
you you had a dialogue with a the mom
who in the Masjid and he had an argument
something that you had said it was very
profound something about if God needed
to have needed something about how did
that argument go about the sacrifice or
crucifixion what was it how was it it
was very profound it's very deep this
goes back to sort of the the depth that
I had regarding ISA and I said I'm being
part of this Trinity so he he profound
of his argument to me that was very
close to my own understanding at the
time and I kind of I felt that at this
point he was very sufficient so
basically he said that if God was
perfect you know that means he doesn't
need anything that means he can't give
anything up he can't get rid of anything
you know he can't lose anything but when
you sacrifice something it means that
you have lost
something and for any for a sacrifice to
have any meaning you actually have to
lose something it can't be symbolic it
can't just be like all alone oh I just
calling it a second question man he'd
feel better know it you actually have to
sacrifice something so for Christian
theology to work they're asking me extra
sacrifice but in order for the concept
of God and Christianity to work he can't
be able to sacrifice he can't lose
anything he always has to be as he is
this goes back to the whole unchanging
nature of God so you know for God to say
that God sacrifices meaning that you're
not talking about God anymore you're
talking about a human being you're
talking about something lower than God
so for me this was sort of the eight
ball in the pocket that kind of closed
it right there to close the deal for for
you coming what was it now the okay cut
actually two more questions okay now you
now that's it you you you read the Quran
you actually you started really feeling
remorse you started to connect more with
it's simple message of only worshiping
the Creator not the creation you came
across that I about being grateful to
God to the Creator about being good to
your parents you went out you you did
what Jesus did and he went a little
further it's it's noted in the Bible and
he fell on his face and prayed to God we
recommend for everyone to try this to
just reach out to the Creator alone it's
in the Lord's Prayer actually calling my
own God just just just God along with
filed any partners you did that you
wanted to be thankful you made the
prostration and for how far from here
did after this did you actually accept
Islam submission to the crater well it
it was a six-month venture about
learning about a song and I think about
two or three months later I finally took
my Shahada like I said baby
it was reluctantly at first because I
was scared but then of course learning
about my past and my history and my
ancestors it gave me that courage to
finally say okay I don't care anymore
yeah I don't know what these people
think I don't care what the society
thinks this is who I am this is me yeah
and I made that jump I finally took my
Shahada I finally gave myself up to
almost Panola Donna and for the next
three years
you know the blessings of Islam and
received many blessings as a result of
coming to Islam but society made me pay
a very heavy price yeah and but I
hundred and I've got over it and I
finally also took the courage to leave
the United States and to venture across
the other side of the world to learn
about my religion family so that your
eagerness to learn more you went to a
university in Malaysia prestigious
university in Malaysian you're actually
doing your this the last question you're
doing your PhD or thesis on the delusion
of the anti Islamic state you know daesh
on the isis but we say the anti Islamic
state those who are actually have
nothing to do with Islam you're doing a
thesis on this and that's why you're
there getting your PhD finish off with
this tell us about that oh okay sure
I'll go be as concise as possible I came
to Malaysia to learn about more about it
Sam I was still doing my education and
philosophy which has helped me
tremendously in dissecting sort of these
ideologies and things that I had been
you know dealing with that I've been
researching and you know actually I had
a friend in the States a young kid and I
was working in a style organization when
I was first converted and I saw him but
it was like maybe 12 13 or so and I
learned when I was in Malaysia a couple
years later that he was attracted to
joining Isis and he got caught and now
he's in jail and that was actually my
first motivation - okay something needs
to be done about this topic so I decided
to take my whole self learning my my
learning in Islamic studies now I'm
doing a PhD in Islamic studies and I
decided okay what is going on here why
are these people doing what they're
doing why are they being extreme why are
they hurting people and now I'm being
like this is called the delusional state
of Isis anti anti Islamic state dice and
I found quite
markedly and though not surprisingly
that many of their ideas are not just
not exotic but are derived from secular
liberal principles from their former
ideologies to about many of the leaders
of Isis Rx Baptist who are secular Arab
nationalists Wow many people don't know
they say that again that many of them
are 117 princes of the top officials Rx
Baptist meaning that they're they were
former secular Arab nationalist under
Saddam Hussein yeah their main architect
is [ __ ] Buckham who was one of the
leading intelligence officers first
Adamu saying in other words these guys
are not you know whatever you want to
call them Salafi Wahabi uh you know you
know these third farthest from that you
can even consider they don't even
understand what they're doing
so you said many of them are second or
less them so and many of them are
atheists I don't know about their
particular theological backgrounds but I
will say that their former ideology they
came from before becoming Isis was
secular Arab nationalism yeah and a lot
of the principles they have about
warfare about war tactics coming that
come from like copy and pasted from
Western textbooks I mean it's not even
it's undeniable if you even read their
treaty seasoned things like this there's
nothing about them that it could be
found it another point seven when they
go to them if it's impossible you know
and epitome of traditional scholars have
come out against them research the way
they think and what they read about and
in the investor in textbooks word for
word in many respects so it's not it's
not it's not it's it's not even well
it's it's not debatable yeah
you look there we'll go tactics and I'm
just making one example I know you don't
have much time and one example is that
their understanding of retaliation when
they say that all they kill our
civilians so we can kill their civilians
okay first off this song is against this
completely okay there's every major
scholar has ruled against this
especially in the context of the end of
the Quran as well ninety when it says
you know fight those who fight you but
do not transgress limits they would say
the limits include not doing what your
enemy does beyond the morality of the
Sharia so you know do not killed if they
kill your suppose they kill your family
do not kill their family member we can't
killer civilians but you know people
like was some up in that and all these
other people they say well that rule can
be changed that's not absolute we can
ignore what these other scholars have
said about that because the West is
doing it to us so we can do it to them
so they're copying and pasting
everything yeah secular liberal
societies yeah why do you think when you
see you had the type of tigers they were
they were actually of Hindi Hindus in
that period from 1980 to 2003 there were
315 completed suicide terrorist attacks
by 462 suicide terrorists who actually
killed themselves and I mean attempts
these are people who actually killed
themselves the world leader during that
24 year period was not an Islamic group
at all they're the Tamil Tigers in Sri
Lanka the Tamil Tigers are a Marxist
group a secular group a Hindu group in
fact over half of those 462 suicide
attackers were purely secular because
you see many Muslims suicide terrorist
groups are also pure purely secular such
as the PKK in Turkey weren't they
they're Hindu but their secular
nationals they're Hindus so that so you
have a comparison there's but we didn't
call we didn't associate this with the
Hindu religion and they were actually
you know doing suicide bombings you know
terrorism and then you
for instance the the IRA I mean clear
Catholics but we didn't say this is the
Catholic State doing this so now you got
there's a there's an even if you go to
higher then there's an Irish joke there
I don't know if it goes like this it
says so one of these terrorist IRA
members walks up to an Irishman he goes
are you Catholic or Protestant and the
guy says I'm an atheist
he says are you a Catholic or Protestant
atheist he shoots it so you know they
don't really care too much for religion
but you see the hypocrisy the double
standard now you have you know these
radical elements the same as you have in
any as the old saying goes there's a few
bad apples in every Bunch and you take
these black sheep and you put them up as
if they're you know representing Islam
you don't you don't see this done as
this example in the title Tigers with
the Hindus or with the the Catholics the
IR the Irish Republican Army who are you
know doing many things you know fighting
for their freedoms and whatnot
you don't associate the whole religion
with these terrorist acts right and
that's this is the standard though of
secular liberal society the military
things depending for instance like you
mentioned we don't take George Bush jr.
who bombed Iraq and Afghanistan and
killed many countless things we don't
consider him to be the example of all
Americans or you know of all the
political you know environments of the
United States you know that would be
unfair but and everyone understands that
they're looking on the outside when
they're looking at their enemies but all
of that changes yeah you know you know
when dr. paape he's actually here and I
have you heard of him in Chicago some
people claim that religion motivates
terrorists
however the academic research of dr.
Robert Pape has proved the claim to be
false
what I did is I collected the first
complete database of every suicide
terrorist attack around the world since
1980 the first version of this database
was published a few years ago and I went
from 1980 to 2003 I think of that is
like the pre Iraq database and then the
second version from 2004 on think of
that is the data that's happened since
Iraq and what the data shows quite
clearly is that the principal cause of
suicide terrorism is foreign occupation
I mean why don't they bring on more
people like this interesting he doesn't
suit the agenda but someone like this
who's a terrorism expert I mean it's
ride isn't he get my he's not Muslim
he's an expert in terrorism as dr. Papa
University I believe of Chicago if I'm
not mistaken who who is quoted he is he
says that you know Islam has little to
nothing to do with these terrorist act
these are all politically motivated
because of foreign invasions because you
see if Islam as sort of a radical
religion or if it were just radical
Muslims doing this then what you would
expect is sort of this thin veneer of
suicide attack kind of scattered all
around the world you would expect that
oh there's 1.4 billion Muslims you know
there's this teeny tiny fringe of
Muslims kind of everywhere who'd be
willing to do suicide attack but that's
not the way the data looks it's really
concentrated and it's really
concentrated in occupations you know
about his about his work yeah
researchers actually have done those
points but the problem is the reason
he's not bitter the reason that people
don't want appointed in the mainstream
is or mainly because if you start saying
that it's not the other person's fault
then you have to start looking on the
inside ah and nobody wants to do that
I'm we're going a little bit over I
think we're gonna have to make this a
double segment I'm really enjoying
talking to you
I I was I'm thinking you know these
people these these radicals who come on
these you know why
you being a philosophy major someone who
is a specialist in air you get into the
psyche of human beings wouldn't it help
if you wanted to solve the problem Ollie
that you brought on mainstream most
people who are out there representing
Orthodox Islam submission to the Creator
not the creation you know and bring them
on fox news bring them on CNN if there
are lost souls which are there in every
community let us have the platform to
call them back and to really show what
Islam is about instead people are out
there like why don't you condemn it as
this common mantra which I mean we don't
have the platform to do so and then you
have these so-called experts out there
who seem to be representing Islam so now
you have this thug like mentality is
gang mentality this guy nice and these
other places who are at nightclubs you
know beating their wives doing
everything opposite basically of Islam
now they go and do something you know
it's like they joined the gang now
they're like already being discriminated
his name is already Mohammed and now
he's learning about Islam through these
radical you know politicians and whatnot
so he starts to think like maybe this is
my religion right so it's us against
them you following me and then he jumps
on but and he does some crazy thing you
get you get what I'm saying so I think
they rat they end up radicalizing more
people themselves these these so-called
you know exploration even by itself is
it is quite it's very big it doesn't
really explain anything because the
bottom line is the reason that these
kids these youth are becoming like this
and I know this is gonna sound
controversial but it's because there are
very much not radicals they're very much
actually very normal people within the
context of the society they live in no
person living a second liberal society
who follow second local standards would
think that it's a bad thing to fight for
one's freedom or to fight against a
tyrannical government or military with
any means necessary
they only don't like it when they're the
oppressors and the rebels on them saying
no doesn't of course ex-excuse killing
civilians obviously is probably wrong
but
you're going to be a society that does
not blink in high or is apathetic or is
passive or for many extremes is
supporting them the civilians that
you're literally slaughtering others
names and cannot be surprised that some
people within a society who are having
an identity crisis will copy those
tactics yeah so the reason they don't
bring on the mainstream and I had
mentioned this earlier is because it
would cause them to have to do a bit of
introspection which for many human
beings whether individualistically
horses or as a society is is an
impossibility France is going through
that right now as well but they did a
recent report I don't know if you're
hurt business is quite fascinating but
most of the foreign fighters joining
Isis are coming from french-speaking
countries why
well the reason is if you're looking at
it objectively is that because it's
French secularism is quite aggressive
and there's a lot of racism within these
societies against minorities however
French populations don't really want to
listen to this part because that means
they have to critique themselves and
change themselves so instead they prefer
to retaliate and bomb for the nice
attacks for instance after the nice
attacks occurred you know they struck
Isis and kill 126 civilians so this is
this is a professional cycle because
because society less women promoting
that proteins reaction in many ways I'm
not saying that the innocent people
should you have nothing formal is going
on between about this to governments and
militaries the people in power
they they don't want to look at
themselves and say okay what am i doing
what am i doing that is poking one exist
or why am i booking or incest you know
they don't want to do this and anytime
anyone brings up with these things who
tries to have a puns approach
okay so there's somebody who's trying to
justify terrorism or justify extremism
and and the whole conversation good show
but nice and work is
this if you want extremism to stop you
need to stop extremism at home and I'm
not talking about your neighbor where
they jet I'm talking about the policy
that your governments are perpetuating
first of all doctor one of my guest
former guests dr. Jonathan Brown he's
here yeah
Professor Jonathan Brown from I believed
your Town University he really talks
about this a lot they don't they hear so
much about Muslims and violence Isis and
all this stuff you look at the number
people Isis ago I don't like Isis okay I
don't support Isis you know there's lots
of things they do that are absolutely
unacceptable but if you look at the
number of people let's say that the
Egyptian government now has in prison
number of people that the Egyptian
government killed since the coup of 2013
I mean you're talking about thousands
and thousands of civilians you know may
be dozens of thousands of people in
prison wrongly being tortured and raped
in prison I mean is you know what what's
the difference between that and Isis
really I mean you know you're talking
about governments or organizations that
kill thousands of innocent people in
prison or torture thousands of innocent
people but no one thinks about you know
here's how about Isis they don't think
about other things that you know so
they're convinced that somehow Islam
leads to these evils but there's exactly
the same number of evils or amount of
evil being done by something that's
obviously on that's not justified by
Islam at all we're not even attempting
to justify itself so I think this is you
know Isis exists because the United
States invaded Iraq and destroyed all
the institutions that country and left
it a complete mess
that's that's a fact okay Isis doesn't
exist because of Islam because Islam was
in Iraq before 2003 and there was no
Sunni extremists there was no sunny
terrorism there was no Isis before 2003
this result this emerged in Iraq at
because of the United States invasion
that's what caused Isis Islam didn't
cause Isis but if you look at the US
media it's obsessed with getting people
to talk about Islam the cause of Isis
Isis because of Islam why does it do
that because the function of media and
government is to prevent people from
actually in this case prevent them from
actually reflecting on the actual causes
of this phenomenon
which is the United States unjust
warmongering
because if people sat there and said hey
wait a second we got talked into
invading this country it was a total
disaster now we have this Isis business
then they might say maybe we shouldn't
go and invade countries the next time
we're asked by our government to support
a war that's not what the kind of power
elites or the military media industrial
complex once they want people thinking
like that so they have to sit and and
place the focus on some other cause it
was cause of Islam they don't want
Americans actually thinking about really
cause these things so when I when I what
I tell ya you know Muslims or even
non-muslims about this is don't be
bamboozled by what you see on TV it's
very simple I mean I know it's obvious
but just because people say stuff a lot
on TV doesn't make it true and also I
had another professor from Loyola
professor Omar and they talk about how
Isis these extreme radical group state
didn't even exist before many of these
they didn't even exist at one time this
is usually right this happened as a
consequence of the unjust wars the war
mongering and and you know this is a
result of that obviously Islam doesn't
condone killing of innocent men women
and children but this is the these are
the consequences of that is that the end
you know Fox News is not going to is not
going to explain it like this you know
they they may say oh yeah we made a
mistake in Iraq but they kind of just
act like it was a bad joke they don't
even they don't have any sort of real
remorse that should be there they don't
they don't want any real change in
suspect and and you're right you're
right
everyone was who was looked at this
objectively said yes but I'll if it had
not been for the Iraq war Isis would not
be here but these these uh
the so-called experts in mainstream are
saying well no they just opened the
forum Bay and all of a sudden they want
to kill people that's transparent that
says argument in a nutshell Oh are they
read the Quran no they want to kill
people I recommend our brother he's got
a great book because I often say yeah
yeah Emmerich I say if you don't if you
don't want to remain an idiot because
you got to be a complete idiot
to think that Islam has anything to do
with such evil acts like that right
so I recommend and what we'll finish off
with that the Complete Idiot's Guide to
understanding Islam you think that's a
good place to start you know brother
yeah yeah I'm Iraq yeah yeah yeah great
book start off with this real simple
keep it easy because again you got to be
a complete idiot to think that Islam is
promoting these evil actions is that
fair assessment brother that is a fair
assessment
thank you very much wonderful story
inshallah God willing we looked forward
to having you back again on a Deen show
what do you think thank you sir and I'd
really be great actually you know
there's a lot to talk about so and I
really feel honored for being here so
thank you so much for writing in thank
you brother thank you so much to suppli
hi assalamualaikum - love constant it's
all of the law subscribe right now